i've been thinking about this concept
for a long time which is everybody who's
driving right now who wants to build a
huge business i don't think really
thinks that kindness and empathy and
compassion and patience are core to
building an empire
and i thought i was the guy to write it
because so much of what i've built and
what i'm going to build is based on
things that your grandma would say you
should do and i don't think that's what
people think about when they're going to
build a 100 million dollar company they
think sharp elbows i'm going to out
negotiate they think sports
and i think what sports men and women do
after a game where they hug and they
talk and you know as a fan i get upset
when the jets lose an american football
game and then they're hugging and
hanging out with the opponents after i
get mad
what are you doing correct but that's
exactly what i think is required of
building a big business and i thought i
was the guy to write it
we hear this word nft yes we think we we
think we understand it or some of us
have absolutely no idea or a big part of
people think it's a scam and it's a fad
and it's coming up on influencers social
media sites and you're like well i'm not
going to get into this people laugh oh
you're doing nfts
you have really shown the world and
you've pioneered it in your platform of
9 million just on instagram alone of
what nfts can do and how they can
operate
can you explain to someone right now and
i know you've been asked this question
before
explain in basic terms what an nft is
it's let me say this before i answer
that question everybody who's listening
right now is going to struggle with the
concept because they're bringing their
internet brain to the blockchain
let me say that one more time
the blockchain is such a different
platform than the internet that when i
tell you that what an nft is is it's a
digital asset that you own most people
don't understand that because they're
like well that doesn't work on the
internet i can right click and save the
image yeah sure
so the same way that in 1994 56 when i
told people that people would buy wine
on the internet and everybody who was 20
30 40 50 thought that was stupid
most people who think nfts are stupid
don't realize that they've become their
mom and dad and grandparents just like
they thought the internet was stupid
email was stupid the iphone was stupid
social media was stupid online dating
was stupid
people don't realize that they are
missing the boat on this technology but
the answer to your question is an nft is
a non-fungible token which is a digital
asset that you actually own and when
people say well why would i want to own
something digitally i'd need to hold it
well a lot of people who are driving
right now want a blue check mark on
their instagram account and guess what
you don't hold that a lot of people want
10 million followers on social media you
don't hold that a lot of people live
their life to take photos on the
internet you don't hold that we are
living a digital life and if you have
children that are buying skins on
fortnite my both my kids love buying
skins well guess what that's a digital
asset and as we go more digital your
clout your status your need to
communicate is happening more digitally
than it's happening in real life people
do things just for a photo on social
media it's human psychology
last of all
it's a smart contract meaning the
digital asset can also mean something on
the back end so for example i have a
huge business conference in minnesota in
may called vcon it's like a south by
southwest coachella of business and the
only way you can get in is if you own a
v friend it is the ticket right
you're also opening up the first nft
restaurant in the world that's right fly
fish club which will open next year
early next year in new york city can i
get membership if you buy
it
that's why he's so rich but it's super
interesting it's super interesting a lot
of people right now especially in this
town they pay for a membership
country clubs soho house all these
things but you pay you don't own an
asset with nfts your membership is an
nft but if you decide after three months
you don't want to come anymore you put
it on the blockchain and you sell it
it's
creating a world where your access or
your membership becomes an asset not an
expense
i understand that so think about that so
the but the nft restaurant that you're
opening up is it is it a it's not a
physical restaurant oh it's a physical
restaurant
yeah this is not the metaverse which i
think is much further away than people
think i don't think we're living in vr
so and people mix metaverse and nft
they're separate things
this is a physical restaurant that is
going to be wildly premium large
location highly in demand that the nft
is just your membership and so that will
open in q1 of next year can't wait for
it garyvee in the studio once again a
big round of applause
yeah
i like this yeah i like that yeah that's
true gary um okay the book come on
you're here in dubai the emirates lit
festival this is your book 12 and a half
leveraging the emotional ingredients
necessary for business success i look at
the back and i love already what i see
gratitude self-awareness accountability
can we talk can we talk about
accountability yeah sure yes like talk
about something the world desperately
needs we want to blame the algorithm we
want to blame our parents we want to
blame the government we want to blame
everything we have become addicted with
pointing fingers and nobody wants a
point of thumb at themselves i believe
most people's unhappiness that are
listening right now are completely
predicated on their lack of
accountability if you are unhappy you
are actually in a position to fix it if
you were listening to this
if you're listening to this you were of
the means to fix it
and i think that accountability is the
breakthrough of the next decade because
we've gotten very cozy
with not being accountable
makes sense right like you're not happy
about your boyfriend break up with him
yeah
as a matter of fact everybody in dubai
right now listening call your boyfriend
that you're unhappy with
and break up let's do all the radios
i mean but rosie you know it's important
like you you can you don't like the car
you don't like the country you're in
move
you're blaming the situation but you
should turn it and look at yourself and
here's the point whether you're right or
wrong your mother might be poisonous but
the second you take control of it you
become happier whether you're right or
wrong about like i think everything is
my fault i'm logical to know that not
everything is my fault but the default
of thinking everything is my fault
actually makes me happy
i get that
let's talk about number nine on your
book and it's one that i've got here
which i've told you about patience yes
because i believe that could you could
you give us your views on just that word
patience the lack of it
is also a huge factor to why people are
unhappy everybody's looking for so much
outside validation that they're
impatient they want to show everybody
that are successful thus they're rushing
into things you have 23 year olds who
think that they don't have their life
figured out yet they're living for
another 80 years patience has been huge
for me most people hear the word
patience and have it confused with
complacency laziness lack of ambition
it's not true i actually think patience
has been foundational my success i
decided to build my dad's business for
him for the first 12 years of my career
that required huge pace patience from
somebody who thought they were great i
didn't even start quote-unquote until i
was 34
patience is huge it's huge and people
don't want to do it because they want
instant gratification and more
importantly instant outside validation
i like
12 and a half leveling the emotional
ingredients necessary for business
success it's out right now gary
vaynerchuk and he's with us in studio
he's going to ask he's going to answer a
few of your questions i know we've got a
few on hold right now i'm just going to
ask them to hold um real quickly uh
mazda keem who is our night show with uh
maz and james uh rarely have i ever seen
her in the morning i don't know that's
probably in my 13-year career
i think i've seen you once in my studio
at this time yeah and you have done it
garyvee you you've got up man i'm very
excited there it is one of my great
accomplishments of my career
okay
honestly i know that you're a huge fan
you're messaging me last week when you
heard gary was coming in what do you
want to say um i just want to say i
follow everything you do gary i actually
um bought a few nfts based on what you
said i bought the mona lisa really i'm
curious yes and then i sold it i'm so
proud of you yes so i i follow
everything you do you never told us
about you doing all this aft stuff did
you make any money um i made a bit of
money but then i had to sell it
why i signed up she needed the cash ah
okay and and you've got your own
business as well i'm sure gary's helped
you do your own thing as well with these
these jackets that she wears are so
amazing so cool they're so cool um so
they're made by afghan women it's called
it's fun by mazz and um i've actually
brought one thank you
is it a male female one
and so what what makes you like what
pushed you to do it
um so actually i saw you here in the
studio two years ago and the concept
originally started with bags yes um but
i'm originally from afghanistan and so
it pays homage to my of course your
relatives and my roots so
your parents migrated from afghanistan
to australia
and now like they're so successful like
maz on the radio future your sister is
on um bbc bbc she's like the main girl
on bbc this is
this is a media family empire and they
migrated from afghanistan with nothing
are you are you producing a lot of tick
tock content for the jackets not enough
this is very disappointing yeah you tell
her yeah
because you told me that as well a
couple of years ago and
yeah we've picked up our game it's still
not no i know i double i don't chris i
double checked on the way here
yes i did you are not listen
when you know when when it's like
telling someone they have to exercise
they're like i'm doing exercise i'm like
you walked on the treadmill for two
minutes
that's where you're at right now i know
yeah so don't point fingers you saw what
you just did
my social media tick-tock tick-tock i'm
telling you it's such a visual platform
all the attention is there right now you
can go viral organically not have to pay
ads it's very unusual it's a very
special platform and for what you're
doing it's highly required thank you so
much yeah i find
instagram ads don't really work for me
they can but they're expensive now it's
mature when you know if i was here in
2013 i would have been like instagram
instagram instagram attention on social
media is like real estate you want to
buy it early enough because once it
becomes mature it becomes expensive
right so
right now tick tock is appropriately
priced okay all right listen man thanks
amazing that was good uh yeah yeah very
good thanks
thanks i don't need to thanks just say
one more time
all right more with garyvee next your
questions and he's going to actually
help us do something on the show you're
going to lo you don't know what you're
launching for us we're gonna help us
launch something okay as long as we're
pretty uh then i'm in there
definitely not for me
it's cool you like it do you ever get
exhausted just like offer an advice
now it's too it's too humbling
yeah you know i think i'm i think
yeah but it's like
i'm almost so
profoundly humbled by it
that i'm incapable of seeing the
negative aspects of it
you know
it's like what a nice
thing from here
i love it does anybody know the wi-fi is
it a arn guest do you guys need it or
not right secret yeah yeah
they don't give up
just hot spot me sure but i'm on a
samsung
will that work for me
do you want i i have no hotspot
okay it's on it should be uh you should
see it
is it super handsomedude49
it's android 8p i see it and then it's
just password one two eight one two
three four five six seven eight
garyvee's in the studio he lands in the
city
and then
it's just go go go go go you just don't
stop you're in and out right yeah i mean
you know i'm a big fan of maximizing all
the time right
so we're here and we want to see
everybody don't waste time right don't
but don't but don't burn yourself out
right like don't waste time but don't
get it twisted i got good eight hours of
sleep on the flight out here and then we
got in late and i got another six like
i'm all about sleep it's just that when
i'm awake
i want to be as efficient as possible
one a personal question about you do you
enjoy driving cars do you have a bunch
of cars like you know we're gonna we
know you've got money you don't buy cars
i don't i don't really understand that
like to me it's all about everyone has
different things they like
i don't wanna i don't understand the
performance of a car i don't wanna go
fast like that's not my jam that's not
your thing no okay well like no jewelry
either no no jewelry like i don't like
things
i like the game i like the process of
being an entrepreneur i don't like the
things that come along with
entrepreneurship i really don't i don't
need the trophies i just need to play my
game okay um a lot of people be
messaging us this morning wanting some
advice from garyvee again he's here in
the uh in the city
for the emirates lit festival the book
is out
now initially
mo let's get you on mate mo uh you
you're on with gary we've got a few
minutes here um what did you want to ask
him
hey gary uh hey welcome to dubai thank
you my friend so gary i've been making
some side business for working on some
side business the past few years and
it's been i'm now making more than
double my salary actually interesting
still insecure about you know leaving
the job i mean i am not really ready to
take the leap of faith and i've been
trying hard to understand what should i
do for the last eight months so i
thought this is a great opportunity to
ask you thank you my friend
my belief is that fear
is powerful and however you were brought
up or what your ideology is on safety
you put having a job
on a pedestal as something that's secure
the logic for all of us listening to
right now is if you're making double
what you make in there it seems like a
very obvious step but i'm empathetic
that you're scared to make that jump
my thing to remind you and people out
there in a similar situation is it's not
very hard
to get another job if you fail
if you leave this job and so for me if
we were friends and we talked all the
time the thing i would always remind you
every day is if you take the leap of
faith and some reason it doesn't work
which by the way if you're making double
your salary as a side hustle if you give
a hundred percent of your time to that i
have a funny feeling it's going to work
out but i would remind you that you
could always go and get a job again in
the same industry maybe for a different
company believe it or not and i've seen
this sometimes for the same company
because they missed you
that's what i would pound into your head
because whatever you grew up with it
created an ideology that a job was safe
does that make sense to you mo yeah
absolutely thank you very much listen
before before you leave you need to
re-listen to that over and over and over
every human being is the byproduct of
what they listen to so if you're
listening to your parents or a plus one
or somebody else that's saying no no no
no no don't make the jump you're not
gonna make the jump if you listen to
somebody who's saying something
practical like take the jump and oh by
the way if it doesn't work you can
always go back and if it fails who cares
about other people's judgment then
you'll jump
wow
thank you mate thanks moe all right love
it you know so many people are
messaging in right now but we know that
you've got to run now before you do we
wanted to kick something off this show
we've been wanting to do this for nearly
about 18 months right yeah yeah yeah
it's about doing this on the show
inspired by your garage sale show yeah
so obviously we want to do our we're
doing the chris fade show swap meet oh
we want to start off with obviously one
object and we want to take it till the
end of the year to see how big we can go
the old red paper clip concept okay
correct now
we figured that we've got you in the
studio we actually probably could be
starting too high yeah this is but is
there anything that you can provide us
with that's our first object and then
what we'll do
is we're going to ask anyone listening
to the show
trade it they've got to swap it and they
may give us something that's of higher
value to the point where
i will own my own private excuse me
excuse you this is not about you oh okay
isn't this all of you yeah it's just one
item yeah yeah so one item and at the
end well let me ask you a question yeah
do you want to feel proud of yourself
like for example if i give you right now
an hour of my time on zoom
the the value of that is very high
what about a signed book that's nice and
humble no you know pretty thank you for
flattering me but that's not like listen
the hour is like
tens and tens and tens of thousands of
dollars i'm back to you for that you
mean the hour yeah well you can
[Laughter]
so you've got listen i'm going to put in
your court you can have a signed book
right which is a nice solid item that i
know a lot of people listening might
want it might trade you something good
or you can take the hour
now let me remind you
kids that are born into a lot of wealth
actually deal with a lot of anxiety and
unhappiness because they're born on
third base
so if i give you the hour
nobody's going to be really impressed
with what you end up with because your
starting point was remarkable yeah i
don't want to start the hour no what i
was saying to coming back to it i'd like
to get to like maybe three months into
the journey and then be like yo we've
just got an hour with gary v like that's
that's
i'm happy to take the i still think the
book is too still too i think it's too
well what about what about an hour what
about a what about a marker like a
sharpie yeah how do you make a doodle
that's more that's worth a million
dollars
i don't know if you've heard but i'm i'm
a yeah i'm a pretty big artist now my
stuff sells at christie's okay so
what what we'll do
why don't we lock in can we take the
hour are you being serious like i'm
being dead serious that's how much i
love you i will i'm absolutely happy to
do it an hour and a half an hour zoom in
my time before the end of the year like
likely june july august
i'm in
well
now to give you a preview of what just
happened
in six months maha is going to email me
and say look you got to do that hour do
you remember and i'm going to be very
upset
that i've come that i committed to this
but now i'm stuck it's on public record
i'm in
are we taking the hour we're taking
everything
by the way we're in dubai i don't know
who listens to the show like you might
get offered a private jet just for that
you might be done here yeah this is good
no i'm i'm you're very you should
everybody who's listening you should see
his face right now chris is very excited
i am i'm gratituding
i'm out accountability of this i'm going
through everything in your book right
now the best thing is we get to keep our
books
so what we're going to do we're going to
bank that hour with garyvee we will bank
that we will officially kick off the
chris fade show swap meet tomorrow with
our first product or our first object
who knows what it's going to be um
garyvee we are we love you man i love
you guys so much for coming in thanks
for having me go and grab the book uh 12
and a half leveraging the emotional
ingredients necessary for business
success
[Applause]
you